Cosmo resumes beautiful welcome to me
[Music]
today we're doing today we're gonna do
the 7 second challenge is requested by
no one might be able to explain the
rules we have to write down seven
challenges before the other person and
obviously since it's called the seven
second challenge we will have to
complete the challenge
come on okay in seven seconds
you have to tell me five dog breeds what
uh hug hug hug hug hug hug
was that a that is not what I asked for
you all sit yes oh so lame okay fine no
points give me one of your hair
[Music]
thank you I'll cherish this always gonna
sell it on eBay yeah you okay you got a
point
Congrats okay I need a point now seven
seconds leave me a sentence from a book
that is that a book that no one likes me
dude journal you're such a jerk
Kyle make what Rick don't bother it's
out what the hell are you reading kind
of smudge points no do an ugly dance
[Music]
yeah okay if you throw up in your mouth
all right Wow it's just in case we're
doing this challenge and you're wrong
okay yes I always pride myself being
baby able to do back back backward
somersaults I think well I think you're
a jerk lick your elbow
[Music]
it's possible shall we
it's supposed to be impossible fine okay
good job
I think that was I could you like
ketchup and it was my last one okay yeah
good job pants 4 4 5 5 4 6 5 4 3 5 3 yes
well there's something we keep the
support sing through your nose your nose
[Applause]
[Music]
you have 7 seconds to put on lipstick on
camera
I'm not three my new lipstick you went
for a date wasn't it was the next day
hey don't worry Jory I know a trick you
put it back on then you put it in the
fridge and it's like all-new I watched I
watched a beauty guru do this so did you
put it up no because you bro no it's
totally they sing a love song in the
cheesiest way possible okay this is a
good one we did seven seconds we have to
describe five in three words
nice beautiful Russian is that was okay
what I wanted to buy your farts please
okay sure okay last for you this is the
game breaker eat candy she always have
it ready feed me
[Music]
all right I got candy whoever wins all
right so we lost count to let us know in
the comments who you think boy I'm not
gonna admit the bro is votes it counts
more than anything I think my singing
skills are just wait I think I have a
hearing issue now but go ahead and hit
that like button if you enjoyed this
video you have 7 seconds and that's all
for now see you in the next one brofist
[Music]